twitter bots are such a big deal that
elon musk put his twitter purchase on
hold just to figure out how many bots or
fake accounts exist on twitter fake
accounts pretend to be someone else or
are automated accounts that don't have a
real person behind them that can do
things like real humans can do send out
tweets like and retweet there's
apparently even a market for fake elon
musk twitter accounts
this is important because it's the
number of real users that determines the
value of twitter so twitter is 229
million daily active users are not 229
million real human beings then musk
argues the company's value is less than
the 44 billion he's agreed to pay for it
musk tweeted that 20 of twitter consists
of fake or spam accounts though he
didn't cite any sources that contradicts
twitter's claim that fewer than five
percent of accounts on its platform are
fake musk says he wants twitter's ceo
parag agrawal to show proof and that the
deal cannot move forward until he does
that wording is much stronger than his
previous tweet that he was still
committed to acquisition hours after
putting the deal on hold when musk
appeared on the all-in podcast in may he
again questioned twitter's claim that
less than five percent of its accounts
are fake so another way the number of
real unique humans
uh that you see making comments on a
daily basis on twitter
is above 95
that is what they're claiming does
anyone have that experience
[Laughter]
[Applause]
i'd like to sell you you know
he also likened his agreement to
purchase twitter to agreeing to buy a
home that the homeowner said had only
five percent termites only to later
realize it's infested and the whole deal
may need to be reconsidered a software
company found the number of fake or spam
accounts is four times higher than
twitter's estimate sparktoro analyzed
profile pictures location data and used
machine learning processes to conclude
nineteen percent of twitter accounts are
fake or spam larger accounts are even
harder hit spark toro said 43 of joe
biden's twitter followers on his
personal joe biden account are fake and
inactive it's even higher for elon musk
the company says 70 of his followers are
fake and inactive why does the number of
fake and spam accounts matter so much
someone who wants to manipulate public
opinion could create hundreds of fake
accounts to criticize a policy or a
politician to influence how you vote
type a product to control what you buy
or make someone seem more or less
popular than they really are a cyber
security researcher believes spots are
responsible for what he calls the
attempted character assassination of
elon musk andrea stropa notes they've
been tweeting out elongate spacex
scandal in reference to the spacex
flight attendant who has accused musk of
sexual assault which musk denies they're
not just interacting with musk's critics
but also his fans so that conversations
can reach a wider audience rather than
the echo chamber of musk haters fake and
spam accounts are influencing public
discourse inauthentically as they don't
represent the views of real people
there are things you and i can do to try
to remove bots from our feed the cyber
security researcher suggests muting some
of your twitter notifications for
example from people who don't have a
profile picture or who haven't confirmed
their email address or phone number
musk has said one of his top priorities
after taking over twitter is to defeat
spambots and authenticate all humans
which would dwindle his follower account
from 94 million down to 28 million if
it's really true 70 of his followers are
fake or spam 28 million is still a
significant follower base but whenever
there are fans you can bet there are
critics many liberals have been outraged
over musk's push for more free speech on
twitter which he believes is being
stifled for example he said he'd reverse
the platform's ban on trump
conservatives have long accused twitter
of censoring their views a twitter
employee recently confirmed the apparent
left-leaning bias at the company this
senior engineer was caught in a secret
recording by the right-wing activist
organization project veritas saying
twitter does not believe in free speech
and admit it some of his colleagues hate
musk's purchase because they're super
left another employee also recorded by
project veritas made it clear twitter is
not only about free speech and then
proceeded to make fun of musk because of
his aspergers calling him quote
literally special needs not that poking
fun at him would get under his skin or
criticism of any kind musk said during a
ted talk interview this year that
criticism over his billionaire status
was quote water off a duck's back he's a
man on a mission to deal with bots and
issues of free speech
if for some reason the twitter deal
doesn't end up going through he could
still be a social media mogul he
mentioned he's considered starting his
own app we've imagined it might be
called elon social
if you'd like to build up your skills in
stem so you can engineer great products
whether it's a social app self-driving
cars or rockets brilliant is an amazing
tool to learn stem interactively their
computer science fundamentals course
will help you strengthen your knowledge
of core computer science concepts and
it's great if you're in high school
college or already working no coding is
required and if you're ever stuck you
can click on show explanation to see
where you went wrong there's something
for everyone on brilliant you can delve
into the world of neural networks
through hands-on experimentation see
fractions percentages and ratios in a
new light through their everyday math
course or learn about the technology
behind cryptocurrencies through hands-on
puzzles
brilliant is free for you to try out if
you head to the custom link in my
description or pin comment brilliant.org
slash newsthink and the first 200 people
to click on my link will get 20 off
brilliance premium subscription which
gives you access to all of their
offerings
thanks for watching for newsthink i'm
cindy palm
[Music]